heads of state and government arrived
for this crucial eu summit to agree
strategy for the next five years sign
association agreements with ukraine
moldova and georgia and decide on their
nomination for the head of europe's
executive branch
the month following the european
elections has seen the usual horse
trading over the eu's future direction
and its top posts what's unusual is it's
ended with an almighty row over the
presidency of the european commission
with 26 member states full square behind
jean-claude juncker and just two britain
and hungary dead against it is not right
for the elected heads of government of
the european countries to give up their
right to
nominate the head of the european
commission the most important role in
europe that is a bad principle and it's
the wrong person eu leaders usually take
the decision by consensus not this time
mr cameron insisted on a vote which he
lost by the expected margin
this is a bad day for europe it risks
undermining the position of national
governments it risks undermining the
power of national parliaments and it
hands new power to the european
parliament among meps whose job it will
be to vote on mr juncker's nomination in
july there was evident relief that the
will of the people as expressed in may's
election was followed through on
if he gets to power will be more
committed to the european parliament and
via this to the european citizens than
all other commission's presidents before
this was not to overshadow other
important items on the agenda not least
the signing finally of an association
agreement with ukraine
i think this is the
most important day for ukrainian history
after
independence day